[music]
If I asked if I asked just that
I would just ask the central street
They said Lenin and they would have guessed 100%.
then I began to approach them one by one and
ask, and none of them could
answer me the name, and people were just waiting for what would happen
in the morning, the body would be abandoned, you already know in the yuzivka,
America is growing noisily around here, in the
evening I will go to Liverpool and the smell of
Freedom will fill the lungs with a mixture
in the miner's field, part of the landscape
for me is the mountains. I know everyone, just
like that, I would like to have my favorite
place with my feet on Saturday.
my
isolation I am a worker in the city of the machine
called Donetsk I live here quietly in my
thoughts I love Ukraine but to live I am
silent for the time being I am a worker in the city of the machine
called Donetsk I live here in the final We are exactly
a part of the country - this is the flag step the
winner of the war who prepares the tables we are waiting
friends without Kyiv  I also wish that the fire
in Moscow destroyed the ignorance of my plane, and
it hurts a lot under the ribs and its
copplenomeri  On April 14, wings are expected in the closet.
Look here, there are three countries
at the airport. There was a whole line for me. She,
you loved freedom and the champion.
Miner, we are his wards with smiles in the park.
Theater actions. Is it a shard? Now I have to
walk brightly through wounds in my heart and blood
on my hands.  a worker in a machine city
called Donetsk I live here quietly in
my thoughts I love Ukraine but to live I keep
silent I am a worker in a city-machine
called Donetsk I live here in the final
We are exactly a part of the country where flags blood
will win the war make forever machine
[music]